welcome back everybody so when it comes
to health right now most of us
might be more worried about getting
covered than anything else but
in this morning's buddy check 8 report
denise valdez reminds us
women need to make their personal
wellness a priority
most women are the caretakers of the
family that's why
it's critical they don't overlook their
own health and annual exams
like mammograms even if they think they
can't afford it
are there some women maybe from
different economic backgrounds who might
be falling through the cracks here in
southern nevada would you say
that can happen um unfortunately they're
under-insured or non-insured
fortunately there are programs available
there's the susan g komen foundation
women's health connection
the american cancer society that can
work as an absolutely fabulous resource
for these women
to help them find programs that will
cover their cost or give them low-cost
exams patty crowl
is the mammography supervisor for desert
radiology
through their seven clinics in the
valley they conduct roughly 600
mammograms a month
a majority of them are 3d it's the new
normal for mammography mammography is
still gold standard even the 2d version
but 3d allows us to do one millimeter
slices through the breast
so we see finer detail we're able to
pick up smaller things in the breast
it's really great for women with dense
breasts but it's good for every woman i
mean it really gives us a ton of detail
it's reduced the number of times the
patients have to come back for
additional views
for safety the clinics now have extended
hours open as late as 11 pm
and on saturdays to accommodate patients
for buddy check
denise valdez 8 news now